honey this is it this is like the
biggest dating site in LA random
encounters is what we're looking for for
people who are too [ __ ] to do
something about it so it's pretty much
for people like you so who's the victim
guy I met online don't judge we're young
I'm adding fun I'm not desperate I
didn't mean like that
mother says I should go meet a girl and
then who's gonna take care of mother
nope look like you're really bored and
have a serious attitude problem
I'm all for old fashioned romance I
don't think people should meet that way
it should be I'm gonna find him the
coffee guy how are you planning on doing
that maybe I'll go back to the coffee
shop I just can't get this girl out of
my mind man I didn't get her name I did
get her number nothing I think I should
go back to that coffee shop maybe she'll
show up again what were you saying
I'm chasing a guy who doesn't exist
honey aren't we all it's just a boy oh I
know I just goes to show you have to be
in the right place at the right time
sometimes you only get one shot
[Music]
you